foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Oh I thought I still had like 15 seconds
my bad that time must have been wrong
then hey everyone uh my name is Miriam
for those that do not know me it's great
to see you all here
um
did you say you love me
Oh I thought you said you loved me she
said no I said I know you
oh man well same thing I'll take it uh
again thank you all for being here I
just have a couple quick announcements
for you first one next Sunday the 20th
is that next Sunday already no two
Sundays from now I'm all mixed up with
timing the 24th we are having our
um after the service state of the table
meeting everyone is welcome to that if
you've ever been interested in kind of
knowing you know the behind the scenes
stuff about the table uh finances goals
leadership transitions where things are
headed and of the sort you're welcome to
attend that that's after the service in
two weeks on the 24th and then next week
now the 24th still gosh I'm all mixed up
with dates we have a special guest
speaker Sally Gary
you some of y'all are like who who's
that Sally Gary is the um leader and
founder of a non-profit called
centerpiece and it's an lgbtq uh
non-profit so she's gonna come that
Sunday and kind of tell us her story and
what they're doing over there she's a
dear friend of the table and a lot of
the members here so
um come out and support her if you feel
you know if you are in town I should say
um yeah that's all I have so uh as I
lead us into kind of a my sort of prayer
that I was going for
um my friend Sarah showed me a book this
weekend and I might get the name except
it's called the boy the mole The Fox and
the horse does anyone know what that is
such a good book and it's like a kids
book an adult book it's so good and it's
All About a Boy a mole a fox and a horse
and how they find friendship and just
the weirdest type of uh relations and
Companions and it's all life lessons
again something that kids and adults
could all take from one of them that
stood out for me is one of our greatest
freedoms is how we react to things and
that kind of stuck with me and what's
funny is is I went I joined a soccer
league an over 30s
saw girly
but I'm still the youngest person on the
team so I'll take that
um and we were playing a game this
morning and the team that we were
playing against was not so nice
um and again over 30 so I'm playing with
you know older women and such and they
just kept getting so mad and like
pushing us over being really rough and
my team was calm cool and collected
and it got to the point where they were
you know fouling us and getting mad at
us for things that they were doing and
it was just interesting it put it into
perspective like
you know you can get angry at things but
how are you going to react to that and
it reminded me of James 1 9 be quick to
listen slow to speak and slow to anger
because there are emotions are temporary
but the lasting effects that those have
on people are not temporary
and I think a lot of people forget that
so my prayer for us going into really
into the week I know we haven't started
a service yet is that we just remember
to be kind right we don't know what
people are going through and ultimately
it's just going to make you a happier
person so I pray that you remember James
1 9 maybe you can remember my story and
maybe you can check out that book and
read it for yourself because it is a
great read and I pray all this for us in
Jesus name amen
Big Ben and it's also now a movie that
you can on Netflix
it's another little plug for that if you
guys want to stand with us we're going
to go ahead and enter into worship and
this first song is one that's been going
through my head a lot lately
um just as we're shifting seasons and
into the busyness of fall and Sports
school and maybe you are in a different
job or maybe it's the same job and
just all the different emotions that we
can face
[Music]
one of the things that God has reminded
me of lately and it's sort of in my
prayer for me and several of my friends
who I know are going through tough times
is that
god
um
we say a lot you know he is with us
valleys the highs and the lows he's
there he's present he's for us and I've
been reminded this week that however
we're coming to him whatever that state
is
appointment and celebration whatever it
is we are coming to him because he has
made us alive he has given us life and
sometimes that's what we're celebrating
sometimes it's just showing up and that
is something to celebrate that is
something to find joy in even on the
dark days so we're still here we are
still taking in breath into our lungs
his blood is still pumping in our veins
and and I pray that tonight that's kind
of a commonality that we can all
celebrate we can all share and celebrate
together is just our presence and
showing up here together to say we
believe that he is for us we believe
that he is good and he will see us
through whatever we're facing
this is a call to all the dead and
disappointed the ones who feel like they
are done
Sizzle were to all the ones who feel
forgotten you are not
and you are not
as we're alive alive
and we're singing we're alive alive
and we're shaking we're alive alive
alive
in you
foreign
[Music]
like the sun on the horizon we're coming
home
we're coming home
we're alive alive alive alive and we're
singing we're alive alive
and we're shaking we're alive alive
alive
in you
sing that with me we're alive we're
alive alive alive and we're singing
we're alive alive
and we're shaking we're alive alive
alive
in you
Lord if you can use us
let us feel your love wash over us
Lord if you can use us fill us up let us
feel your love rush over us
Lord if you can use this fill us up let
us feel your love rush over us
Lord if you can use us fill us up
let us feel your love rush over
it's we're alive alive alive alive and
we're singing we're alive alive
and we're shaking we're alive alive
alive
in you
this is a call to all the dead and
disappointed the ones who feel like they
are done
this is a word to all the ones who feel
forgotten that they
are not
you are not
kiddos are dismissed
if you are four years old through first
graders
classroom to my left and second through
sixth is
thank you
they might need help getting into the
classroom
[Laughter]
all right
we're gonna read the prayers of the
people and if you guys would read it
aloud with me together just um in
solidarity we want to hold the things
that we're carrying heavy on our hearts
up before God and as a community we want
to hold them for each other and make
space
for what we're going through so after we
read this aloud together we'll leave
some space for you to speak aloud a name
or a situation that you're carrying on
your heart and if you're with us online
you can leave that in the comments and
then we'll close out the rest of the
prayer together
read this with me
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or pers other
perceived difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
in situations up to you
[Music]
for Katie
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
the empty filled the wounded healed the
broken back together
the poor are blessed the weary rest we
will Dance Forever
[Music]
foreign
the blinded sea the chained are free the
doubtful now believer
the outcasts known the orphan home you
are my redeemer behold
behold
Behold The Love Can Do behold
we heard
he's making all things new
[Music]
the last return the voiceless heard the
morning now rejoicing
the mountain shake the world awake
creational
composing the sad and true the Earthly
news the song has found its singer the
darkness light the deadline if you are
my redeemer behold
he holds please
[Music]
behold
he's making all things new
we've been stood down we're not
destroyed
we've sewn into
[Music]
we're not destroyed we
we Zone in tears
open hey hey
[Music]
my eyes
open
[Music]
foreign
he's making all things new behold
behold
behold looking to be whole
he's making all things new
[Music]
God would we believe that you're doing a
new thing
would we believe that you can bring
restoration Redemption
hope
and forgiveness
no matter what we're facing
you are at work
you are here
[Music]
thank you
oh this pain
I wonder if I'll ever find my way
I wonder if my life could really change
at all
foreign
[Music]
could all that is lost ever be found
could a garden come up from this ground
can you make beautiful things
you make beautiful things
you make beautiful things out of the
Dust
yes guys
you make beautiful things
you make beautiful things out of us
[Music]
all around
out of chaos life is being found
in
[Music]
you
make beautiful things you make beautiful
things out of the Dust
you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things out of us
[Music]
oh you make beautiful things
you make beautiful things
[Music]
oh wow
you make me new you are making me new
[Music]
you
may make me new
you are making me new thank you
[Music]
you make me new
you are making me news
[Music]
oh sing you make beautiful things
you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things
[Applause]
Christ
you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things
[Music]
to make beautiful things you make
beautiful things
you make beautiful things you make
out of ice
you make me new
you are making
be new
you
make me new
you are making me new let's sing that as
a prayer
you make me new
you are making me do
you make me
you make me new
you are making me do
here
Scott we want to believe that
we want to trust that you are doing a
good work in us and through us
that you are the author and the
Perfecter of our faith
God would you continue to write our
story
continue to weave in your hope
and your blessing
weave in your good news
and God where we can't believe it would
you help us with our unbelief
foreign
new ears
would you repair the broken places in
our heart
we love you and we thank you for what
you're doing in us and in this community
in Jesus name
amen
will you turn to the people around you
and welcome them say hello and then
Brett will get us going on the next part
of our service
all right
if the Elder team
and
our our newest
Elders could come on come on don't be
shy Raymond give them a hand as they
come up okay Raymond where's Marissa
here she's making her way
here she is give Marissa a hand too
all right y'all come here you come like
Center
they'll come in the middle
and then Gary come on over don't be shy
Max don't be shy all right
um well
so tonight it is this is a special night
very special
um because about it was probably five
months ago now we
um put out kind of the The Feelers to
all of you we talked about it here on a
Sunday I sent texts and we kind of
solicited like feedback because we
needed to
um add new members to our Elder
leadership team which for those
unfamiliar is sort of uh the team that
that helps oversee all things here at
the table
um so like I'm a part of the team but
it's a good thing to have a team and not
just a uh Tyrant you know like a pastor
just the dictator like oh just make all
decisions like no no that's not how we
do things at the table uh so I'm
submitted to this team and so we knew we
needed some new folks so we kind of put
out feelers and the names that came up
over and over and over again
um are these two right here Marissa
Martinez Raymond luster and so they have
now been in kind of just a season of
discernment
um for probably four for four months I
think and so they've been like attending
our meetings and kind of functioning
like elders
so that they can kind of get a feel for
like what's the what's the thing you
know what is this all about and uh so we
meet every other week so they've been
coming to those very long meetings and
um and so we uh like was it probably two
weeks ago we just got through feedback
like is this something you're interested
in pursuing and very happily they said
yes so tonight what we're gonna do is
um kind of I didn't really even know the
right word like Commission
I don't know something you know we're
gonna like make this official so we've
got like a little liturgy
um there'll be parts that I will read
there's Parts
um for Raymond Marissa to read and then
there's also parts for all of you
because this isn't
um just you know about us or them but
it's really us all of us as a community
saying hey we affirm you in this calling
and we love you and we're for you and
um we're even open to receive you know
from you and uh so that's kind of the
the heartbeat behind us so what I want
to invite you to do is stand
Stan I know you were just standing but
stand again
and so I'm going to go ahead and read
some of this and my my parts and then
you all can jump in it'll be pretty
clear because it'll say you know like
pastor church I mean it's it's pretty
clear so don't be nervous all right so
Raymond and Marissa You Are by God's
grace to be received as Elders at the
table
we have discerned that you are persons
who though imperfectly
consistently embody the character of
Christ and possess signs that the grace
of God is upon you
because of your profound commitment to
serve and love Jesus Christ both here at
the table and outside these walls we
believe that you are called to this role
of Elder
so do you accept this calling and
responsibility
[Laughter]
flawless
church do you trust that Marissa and
Raymond
are worthy by God's grace to be
commissioned and recognized in this role
go to go to the next one
oh this you say we do thanks be to God
there you go well you uphold and support
them in their Ministry
will you speak the truth to them in love
when Marissa and Raymond speak the truth
to you in love will you receive it
amen so we're going to do now is the
elder team is going to gather around
these two and Maggie is going to pray
for them and what I want to invite you
to do if you're comfortable is just kind
of extend your hand out
just as a sign of agreement so it's not
just Maggie praying her Lonesome prayer
but we're you know we're all engaged in
this so you can go ahead and lift your
hand out and let's pray for them
congratulations six says live creatively
make a careful exploration of who you
are and the work you have been given and
then sink yourself into that
don't be impressed with yourselves and
don't compare yourself with anyone else
each of you must take responsibility for
doing the creative best you can with
your own life
and we just lift up Raymond and Marissa
to you God not only because we trust
that they will do that but we've been
watching them do that God already
and
um I'm so deeply grateful for the eyes
that you've given both Raymond and
Marissa to see your children
and to see those who other people might
not call your children and to see them
as a child of God and to call that out
and to be patient and to nurture that
and love on that and God we affirm that
we thank you for it and God we ask that
you would give them a new measure of
grace and patience and
also discernment and intuition God of
how they can use those gifts to serve
your body to serve the table and the
world
God we also pray that they would walk in
confidence never striving or feeling the
need to perform but knowing that they
are already so pleasing to you God that
they already have your yes your amen
your favor your blessing God and we ask
that they could walk with confidence in
that God that when they stumble they
would know that that is a chance to
reach out to you again to come back to
you
and God I ask that we would be good as a
body at embracing them in those moments
and being your hands and feet to them as
well
we ask your blessing your covering your
protection
and your passion to fuel them each day
in Jesus name we pray amen
amen
amen thank you all we love you thank you
I love you
um can y'all give them a hand
and I should also mention Don Jacobs
um had to step away so he wasn't able to
um be here tonight but he's also uh on
the oh he's filling in here okay I knew
I saw him and then he disappeared
um oh that's right we had someone um who
uh couldn't do kids ministry night so he
jumped in that's part of the Elder team
Colin you just uh kind of jump in so
um all right well it is so good to be
with you all so so good and uh my name
is Brett and I want to
um also welcome this join us online love
y'all lots you're not forgotten and um
everyone here who is new thank you for
for being with us tonight I mean your
presence means a lot a whole lot so we
are in this is part six
in our series it's been going a while
when you say part six and next week
we'll be wrapping it up
um but our series is the Book of James
we've just been looking at some of the
major themes and
um kind of insights from this book and
it is it's it's been wonderful I love
it's so practical
um it's also incredibly kind of like
fiery passionate and that definitely
comes through in our texts tonight
um I would call them they're spicy and
so the title of the message is money and
shadows money and shadows we have
um two passages so the first is from
James chapter 2 verses one through six
these are a little bit lengthy but again
they're pretty spicy so I don't think
I'll like lose you
um James writes this my brothers and
sisters
Believers in our Lord Jesus Christ must
not show favoritism
suppose a man comes into your meeting
wearing a gold ring and fine clothes and
a poor man in filthy old clothes also
comes in if you show special attention
to the man wearing fine clothes and say
Here's a good seat for you but say to
the poor man
uh you stand there or sit on the floor
by my feet have you not discriminated
among yourselves and become judges with
evil thoughts
listen my dear brothers and sisters has
not God chosen those who are poor in the
eyes of the world to be rich in faith
and to inherit the Kingdom prom he
promised those who love him
but you have Dishonored the poor is it
not the rich who are exploiting you are
they not the ones dragging you into
court
and then here just right towards the end
of the book is James chapter 5 verses 1
through 6. now listen you rich people
I told you it's pretty spicy weep and
wail because of the misery that is
coming on you your wealth has rotted
moths have eaten your clothes your gold
and your silver are corroded their
corrosion will testify against you and
eat your flesh like fire you've hoarded
wealth in the last days look the wages
you failed to pay the workers who mode
your fields are crying out against you
the cries of the Harvesters have reached
the ears of the Lord Almighty you've
lived on Earth in luxury and
self-indulgence you've fattened
yourselves in the day of Slaughter
you've condemned and murdered the
innocent one who was not opposing you
some there's kind of Echoes there of the
prophets if you've read any of the
scriptures and folks like Hosea and
Isaiah and Amos
um sort of Echoes there of that that
kind of prophetic uh
kind of energy and a willingness to call
a spade a spade you know just
um yeah very very powerful so where I
want to actually begin though is
um with a little quote it was just like
a little throwaway line from an
interview I heard with Father Richard
Rohr The Franciscan monk and he said
this people's attitudes
towards sex money and Authority are all
in the shadow world
they aren't easy to talk about logically
people have such deep irrational
feelings about these things
it's a really profound insight and I
want to unpack this a little bit so he
mentions
um Authority you know what does he mean
by Authority I think he's talking about
power you know when someone has
authority over us power over us like we
feel it and we're tuned into it and that
can stir up all sorts of feelings
especially depending on um how certain
authority figures treated us when we
were younger you know it's sort of like
whoo
you start feeling feelings
um
the other language uses here is shadow
kind of Shadow world like what's Shadow
world so here he's referring to the
those kind of unconscious parts of
ourselves our own minds like that that
kind of way in which all of us are sort
of mysteries to ourselves which is a
very weird thing to think about like you
would think I don't know if I know me
I'm me how can I be unclear on me
but we are aren't we like we're all a
little bit like we're like and the way
you know this is sometimes things just
jump out of you and you're like
had no idea that was in there you know
like you're watching a movie and all of
a sudden you're just sobbing you're just
crying like beyond what the movie called
for you know and it's like oh okay
stirred something up in me or there's
like a certain character trait in
someone that you you just get infuriated
over like it just touches something and
you're just like
um not always but often that is because
um that's like a character maybe flaw in
you that's partly why you can see it so
clearly in them it's in you and you're
like really yes angry at them but also
kind of weirdly angry at yourself but
then it gets expressed to them does that
make sense like I've actually in light
of this I was re-reading these passages
it kind of just got me thinking like I
wonder if James struggled a little bit
you know I mean like in essence if
that's where some of that I mean not
only has he seen the Injustice and such
which we'll get to
um like he's seeing real things but also
maybe he added some of his own struggles
and I'm totally just speculating here
I'm not saying that's like in the text
clearly but it's just there might be
something to that you know often when we
find ourselves really getting worked up
um it's it's kind of a a sign of that so
Roars in essence he's kind of suggesting
that our relationships too not
everything but like certain things
um to sex to money to power uh these
it's deep waters for us stirs stuff up
in us and it makes it um these topics
very difficult to talk about as he names
kind of logically rationally like just
you know maybe other language could be
objectively you know just sort of let's
just have a you know just an objective
conversation about power and how that
plays out in the world and you know it's
sort of like oh
get ready you know like It's Tricky or
money
um same thing
um sexuality same thing right we often
back you can kind of see that in culture
like things that are very tightly
regulated sexuality in every culture is
like pretty tightly regulated because
it's sort of
um it's a powerful thing but also it's
this it's kind of people have deep
feelings about it and it kind of can
spill over and it like it's just a bit
of a lightning rod uh and so you can see
where it's sort of these things are like
you know even maybe I don't know you can
imagine like a family member a mother or
father saying like well you know in
polite company we just don't talk about
that you know and that's why it's sort
of like let's just talk about anything
but what we're really feeling you know
um but this is like this stuff it does
it stirs us up and
um
that kind of murkiness
it sort of um comes through
In this passage
we just read could you can kind of feel
the emotions you can feel this is not
just some sort of cool calm collected
objective you know theological discourse
on money this is a prophetic emotional
like Wallop you know it's like he's
feeling it and there's kind of Echoes if
you were here a few weeks ago we um
talked about there's a different passage
in chapter two where he's talking about
the tongue the power of the tongue by
which he's using a metaphor for like
speech words and it's very similar
but he's just he's all James is worked
up and passionate and like who can tame
the tongue he's like the tongue set on
fire it sets your life on fire it is
itself set on fire by hell I mean it's
like very intense and
now we kind of named it's not because
he's like overreacting
in the same way I don't think he's
overreacting to money I think it's he
just he recognizes like just like with
speech like it's so powerful that was
the thing we named a few weeks ago you
got to recognize the power of words like
wow
and I think it's something kind of
similar
um going on here so James has he has
these like three critiques right
um the first is favoritism
James is hacked off at the favoritism
happening in in churches uh around money
and of course he paints this sort of
delightful terrible scenario I mean I'm
just imagining like if
you get the table Lord have mercy I hope
we don't you know play to this but just
imagine someone comes in you know and
like I don't know maybe they pull up in
the Mercedes or Jennifer I don't know
whatever it is you know and we're just
go oh welcome well you know it's like
the red carpets being rolled out like oh
here sit up here this is always where
Pastor Brett sits he's always right here
so you should you know join him you know
it's just like this sort of disgusting
fawning over you know
um
I think I probably used to be even more
sort of furious and maybe even a little
judgey around churches and these things
now having led a few churches in done
like church Plants and Things I do
realize like where this is coming from
you know you're starting a church and
like times are tight in fact I worked
even before this at a much larger church
and guess what times were tight alway
like it doesn't matter it doesn't like
oh once we get to 100 people once we get
to 200 once we get to 300 people oh then
every you know all our money problems
gone like no it's just not how it works
right so I can I get it but you can see
where oh my goodness we have got to
fight this impulse like no and you can
see it play out where he says you know
then someone poor comes in and we're
just like oh just wait like yeah in fact
I bet they're just here for a handout
I don't even think they care about the
Lord
and so James is just he's just furious
and
um
rightly so
rightly so money is difficult it lives
in the shadows it messes things up it it
splits communities it splits families
like it's a it's a fire it's a hot mess
so that's his first critique favoritism
second critique is exploitation and
Injustice
and uh you know it's kind of interesting
um
that a lot of the what we call now the
major like world religions or whatever
um all sort of came of age right around
the time that money came of Age Two
um before like go back way thousands of
years in human history and you had a lot
of barter trade you know it was like the
the world was one big Settlers of Katan
um do you have anyone play that game
it's so fun I like that guy I'll give
you two weed for three stones or
whatever I don't know
um and right that was sort of you barter
traded um but then you have this new
technology on the scene
and called money you've probably heard
of it
and it like takes the World by storm and
it really it changed things this is why
I think um most of those you know kind
of major world religions are also quite
critical because they could see this new
technology and sort of what it was doing
I think
um there was probably always
um this kind of Injustice you know and
such but
um like all of a sudden it's sort of
really starting to run amok um some of
this is because you're getting cities
like that are growing to hear this 5
000 10 000 people
imagine
City I mean like they estimate that
Jerusalem at its peak was 20 000 people
which is kind of remarkable to think
about like what
um
but it was a problem because it used to
be barter trade just little Villages you
know everyone knew everyone like imagine
if our village was this big like
everyone you knew and ever would meet
was right here
like I mean that would be a different
world right and you can imagine there
you can kind of trade and you kind of
remember like who owes who and you know
what I mean and like oh
you borrowed the eggs from me I need the
milk you know whatever like right you
can kind of do that but with all of a
sudden you start getting growing cities
it gets impersonal you don't know
everyone so money comes on the scene and
people start taking advantage he names a
few concrete things he says you've uh
this is verse six of chapter two you've
Dishonored the poor is it not the rich
who are exploiting you are they not the
ones who are dragging you into court
what's going on there it's like this
right the court system's always been
sort of vulnerable to abuse
um because it's not like judges are
making millions you know and so what do
you do you pay them off and you get a
favorable sentence and or at least in
our day and age a law you're up you know
12 lawyers and just argue it from every
or just drag it through the system so
the poor person can't even keep up like
it would cost them like a few hundred
grand just to go all the you know and
it's just abuse and exploitation
apparently times haven't changed much uh
and then he mentions in five verse 4
says look the wages you failed to pay
the workers who mode your Fields they're
crying out against you the cries of the
Harvesters they've reached the ears the
Lord Almighty so this is where you
promise to pay someone a certain amount
and then payday comes it's like ah well
sorry you know we don't have 300 in our
eye but we got 100 so just make do you
know and then you're like well that's
not fair I'm going to take it to court
they're like all right you do that you
know just like oh my God so you can see
where this becomes a huge problem the
third critique um I mentions is hoarding
there's five verse three you've hoarded
wealth in the last days what is hoarding
well it's basically just amassing more
and more and more and more and more you
can see where money itself as a
technology really lends itself to
hoarding because even though James is
kind of trying to say like it's gonna
rot it's gonna rust it's gonna corrode
you know but we all know like well yeah
but it'll take a while James like you
know gold isn't just falling to pieces
um whereas you think right turn back the
clock in human history I mean imagine if
you were like a farmer and you had all
these crops like it would be kind of
weird to just store up like more corn
corn for decades you know it's just like
weirdo like that's gonna go bad man you
can't just keep it you know but money
well that'll last
Generations you know so you can see
where all of a sudden it kind of Lent
itself to this culture of like yes more
more more more more
so this is where um this is where James
is coming from
and
um it's also by the way I think largely
where Jesus is coming from when he has
some some comments about money
um
and
and so I think kind of an obvious
reaction in light of all this in the
Christian Community is to just feel
maybe even feel in this message like it
just kind of feels like money is just
kind of icky
just like ah it corrupts it just uh and
so I think the Temptation is it just
sort of distance you know and just kind
of be sort of against it or like just
don't like it
don't want to think about it don't want
to deal with it just eh
um not too dissimilar than how we could
be with these other things that Roar
mentions kind of live in the shadows
right power
I go hooray let's talk about power I
mean imagine that's next week's sermon
on power you know it's not but you know
I mean it would just be like oh gosh
like it's just these we just kind of I
mean who wants to think about power have
power you know even have all these
sayings of power corrupts and absolute
power corrupts absolutely and you know
it's just this thing that we're just
like let's just nah I don't want to
anything to really do with that I'm just
gonna
you know be distanced from it
um
and I think this becomes
um sort of problematic though
and uh the way I'd kind of try to frame
it is is this I'll just say money is um
it's difficult
that was the most profound thing I could
come up with all week I had like two
weeks on this money is difficult that's
my conclusion that's it all right y'all
can go um money is difficult it dwells
in the shadows of our life
kind of haunts us
like power or sex we either lust for it
insatiably
or want nothing to do with it can you
see the extremes like the Temptation
towards extremes like yes or just like
oh oh God no or maybe even both in the
same life heck maybe even the same year
or same week like she's like oh no no no
no no just nothing it's terrible it's
horrible okay that's the purpose of like
you know we just sort of pulled back and
forth
um with these things
we either Lust For insatiably or we want
nothing to do with it but both of those
ruin us somehow it seems money Must Be
Tamed and yet who contained The Almighty
dollar
amen
um
it is It's Tricky I think maybe where I
at least personally I feel a little
vulnerable
um
is
where I'm kind of going on a limb is
saying both of those ruin us because I
think just based on these kind of
prophetic like whack of a text
um it kind of feels like I don't know
the the thing to be would just be
against money you know I mean just yeah
it's horrible all those terrible rich
people out there can you believe them
and then we can all kind of go home you
know patting ourselves in the back like
well at least not talk about me you know
um but I want to problematize it a
little bit maybe that's my nature y'all
know I'm always like problematize it
like no isn't this kind of about us too
though isn't there like not as easy as
just like those horrible people out
isn't there something in this for us you
know and not where I don't want to go is
quite where James Goes is just sort of
to um the metaphors to beat the Sheep I
don't want to do that you know just like
ah all you people are horrible with
money not that but but to say like okay
God what is there something in this for
me
um because I think I think there is
and um
you know to say not only not just like
the love of money is the root of all
evil that's sort of what I'm tempted to
say is just like yeah money is the root
of all evil
um and yet I just
I mean kind of like you could say power
is the root of all evil
um and then abdicate it entirely
and not even really recognize your own
power
and realize you know I mean like
and so it just even feels like
abdication like just sort of letting go
is like nah I don't think
um that's the answer
and so I guess that kind of brings to
the question like what are we gonna do
what's the answer like what what do we
do I mean I was thinking um
of like okay
people here I started doing some like
back of the napkin kind of math
um if if you hear anyone here makes like
say fifty thousand dollars a year
if that was sort of your career no
raises nothing you just were like a
school teacher or something back in 2005
or whatever and you just fifty thousand
and you stayed right there
um I guess after 30 years guess how much
money would have flown through your
hands so to speak 1.5 million dollars
like isn't that kind of crazy to think
about like so that's that to me that
seems like the danger of just like well
I just don't want to think about money
that's just gross and that's just this
is those rich people's problem this is
not my problem you know
um
no I
know it is I think there's something to
it in essence I might say in the same
way Christians must develop character
around the wise use of power speech and
sex we must do the same around money
this cannot be avoided without
abdicating a massive responsibility
I know I sound like my grandfather or
something but
nonetheless I really do think that's
true
um I came across a a book it had a
clever little title it was from monk to
money manager
and it was a guy named Doug lynam I'm
fascinated by his story so I didn't read
the whole book I just read this opening
sections where he like describes his
story the rest of the book is sort of
like Financial advice or whatever that's
cool
um but his story I was so intrigued so
Doug Lyman he was born in a very
extremely wealthy family
um
and he saw firsthand the
the kind of Horrors that can be like it
was just sort of awful like they used
money to manipulate one another either
by giving it to manipulate or
withholding it began to sort of you know
carrot stick thing
um
and so by the time he graduated high
school he decided like you know what I
want nothing to do with it I'm done I'm
I I don't want to deal with money so he
dropped out the culture this was a few
you know a few number of decades ago he
became a hippie
and did that for a while eventually kind
of grew disillusioned with that it sort
of became sort of weirdly selfish like
there was no no bigger Vision that him
and his hippie friends were pursuing no
Act of service really so he was like
okay so he stops that he then joins the
military this guy is swinging the
pendulum he goes hippie to military he
loves the structure
um the sense of discipline the sense of
sort of service and a call to something
bigger
um does that for a few years eventually
his conscience he started he I think he
was in the Marines he felt kind of weird
about being taught to enjoy killing that
was his words
so he's sort of like okay
not gonna do that so he finishes his
kind of four-year thing gets out of that
um becomes a monk and says like
I found it my dream job he's like it had
it kind of had everything I was looking
for like it was Counter Culture like the
hippies
um but it had like discipline just like
the military and this whole rule of life
he had to follow and he said best part
of all I never had to think about money
it was just his it was like his dream
job so he's there in the monastery very
happy
for a few years and then he starts
hearing the whisperings
things aren't so good
with the monastery finances
and the long story short well here's
here's what's interesting so he gets
into they for some reason I don't know
if it was his background or college
education or something for some reason
he's he's brought into the inner
workings
and
um
what he finds is they so the monks they
actually did work they worked as school
teachers administrators
so it wasn't like there was no income or
something
um but because they were monks you know
they no one really wanted to deal with
the money
you know just sort of like eh
and so no one did
um or at least those who did were doing
it very poorly and very half-heartedly
and so he gets in and he realizes like
oh my gosh
um they're right on the edge of
financial ruin then a natural
catastrophe happens the monastery roof
caves in
and he realizes like yo
we are sunk we can't pay for it and he
literally over the next few months
walks the monastery and each individual
monk because they had been living off
credit cards for years and they had
taken them out in the names of the monks
a disaster so he walks them all through
personal bankruptcy
and he eventually though kind of leads
them through this experience they're
able to kind of restart years down the
road and then he eventually kind of
finds a passion for helping other people
through their financial disasters thus
from monk to money manager
um but I adore this story because I
think oh my gosh that's it it's a
parable
of like modern
Christians like where it's just sort of
like
money is unspiritual it's icky it's
gross it lends itself to all the
injustices that James outlines
I don't want anything to do with this
and yet money lives in the shadows of
our life does it not
and it even if we ignore it somehow it
does not get to ignore us you know what
I mean like it's there
and it becomes a problem it eats our
lunch and suddenly our roof our
financial roof has caved in
and we too are living off credit cards
and um
stressed out of our minds and worrying
about the very thing we're seeking
constantly to avoid
you know
um
so in the modern world it seems that an
inescapable aspect of following Jesus is
learning to wisely spin save give and
invest
our money
and uh
what I want to do kind of here in
closing I realize this has been sort of
a heavy one like Womp
um
I think what I want to ask is I'm really
curious you don't have to like say it
out loud but I want you to take a moment
and just kind of tune in to your own
feelings
like what's come up for you in this
message you know is it is it guilt
is it fear
I don't know maybe it's passion and
excitement you're like this is my
favorite of all topics I don't know um
you know whatever what's come up for you
and here's the thing I want you to ask
yourself is what might be the invitation
for you in that you know rather than
just
guilt-tripping or despair or there is no
hope for me or you know
um but what might be the invitation of
Christ for you in that and then what I
want you to do is this week in your
Meetup
um or if you're not in one of our small
groups maybe with a friend or your
partner or someone you know someone
um have a conversation with them about
like what's coming up for you and what's
the what's the invitation from Christ
for you in all this and my hope is that
we could become a community of people
who who by God's grace somehow
tame that Almighty dollar
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight
as we
take in the body of Christ in the bread
the blood of Christ and the wine it
strikes me
the way that Jesus Takes all of the like
ordinary
quote-unquote unspiritual things of this
world whether it's money or power
or Bread and Wine just like normal
everyday stuff and turns it into a means
of divine grace turns it into a holy
moment where we actually meet God in the
midst of it and so as you come forward
tonight
that's the invitation that's the the
heart posture I want you to come with is
a sense of meeting Christ in the
ordinary so the way we'll do this we'll
start here at the front row and we'll
just kind of work our way back we
practice what's called an open table
I mean if you're here tonight and you
would like to participate in this then
you are welcome to do that if there's
something you that wants to connect with
the Risen Jesus maybe you're like I
don't know if I have all the right
theology or what denomination are y'all
and whatever
um just if there's something in your
heart that wants to do this then you are
free to come forward having said that
there's no pressure If you're in a place
where you don't want to that's fine too
the red is wine real wine and the white
is grape juice so just a heads up on
that and then finally you can just
partake whenever you'd like immediately
you can return to your seat and partake
but no one will like walk you through
you know the taking of the elements you
can do that
um on your own so this is the table
not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often in you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who have failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
we're going to close with take my life
and let it be and the lyrics of this
song always speak to me just because
it's in the spirit of whatever I have
God
and tonight in light of the subject of
money God whatever I have whatever
you've given me
it's yours
I'm not grasping it I'm not trying to
control it I'm giving it over for your
good first and so would you guys stand
with us and join us as we close out with
this prayer
Gary's gonna lead us in it but you guys
go ahead and sing out with him
[Music]
take my life
take my moments
and my days
let them flow in ceaseless
praise
let them flow in ceaseless Ray
[Music]
take my silver
and my goal
not
a might would I withhold
take my internet
[Music]
Thou shalt choose
everybody
that thou shalt you
[Music]
my will and make it
thy it shall be no longer than
I take my heart it is
[Music]
[Applause]
take my love
my Lord I pour
at thy feet its treasure store
take myself and I will be
[Music]
all for thee
thank you
[Music]
church I want to thank you all for being
here this evening
we love having each of you here seeing
your faces on Sundays if you are new and
you haven't filled out one of our
welcome cards they're located in this
foyer on the little table Little White
cards if you could fill that out let us
know your name that way we can reach out
to you follow up and make sure we can uh
you know poor love and support your way
and get to know you a little bit better
um if you are in need of any sort of
prayer
positive words affirmation whatever it
may be feel free to come find me after
the service or any of our elders and
we're happy to give you a hug and a word
of encouragement
here at the table we are focused on
creating a safe space for everyone here
and a lot of our ability to do that
comes from you all myself included and
giving is a way that helps us do that so
if you feel led to give financially you
can either fill out one of those white
cards on the table in the foyer or visit
us at
thetabletx.org to do so just a quick
reminder of our two announcements two
weeks from now we have our guest speaker
and then
um are meeting after the services well
if you're wanting to get to know more of
the behind the scenes stuff of the table
and what we go through so I'm going to
send this out with a benediction you can
stand in a posture of receiving you can
close your eyes whatever you're
comfortable with but I'm going to send
this out send you out this week with our
benediction
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and this
is true on your worst day
so as you go into your week with your
yet to be
determine highs and lows and everything
in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to anybody
that you come in contact with
be blessed have a good week and we'll
see you next Sunday thank y'all
[Music]
take my moments in my days
foreign
[Music]
yeah
thank you
started I think I hate it when y'all
don't get it
thank you
I'm sorry about the first note
the first note I played
not right I get so into singing that I
like forget to sit the whole set
first note yeah